Rarely is an actor a true overnight sensation.
It takes a lot of hard work, dedication and
persistence to achieve a decent amount of
fame in Hollywood and that may include taking
on tawdry roles along the way.
While some famous actors may start out in
bad slasher movies or student films with stilted
dialogue, others pay the bills by appearing
in something much more indelicate.
Here are 10 Famous Actors Who You Didn’t
Know Did Adult Movies.
Cameron Diaz
Cameron Diaz became one of the hottest and
most sought after actresses to hit the big
screen after she made her debut in 1994’s
The Mask.
She continued her massive success in films
like Charlie's Angels, Gangs of New York,
and ironically enough, Sex Tape.
.But before she hit it big in Hollywood, she
was a struggling model who did photo shoots
for teen magazines but it was a completely
different kind of photo shoot that created
a mild media stir.
In the early 90’s two years before she starred
in The Mask, she did a nude photo shoot that
also included light bondage.
The photo shoot just happened to be filmed
on video as well.
After Cameron became a big star, the scummy
photographer decided to sell his footage.
Even though Diaz blocked the release, the
video still ended up on the internet.
Cameron Diaz’s brief moment on camera acting
out raunchy behavior may seem mild compared
to other adult films, but it certainly is
unexpected for a bubbly cheerleader from Long
Beach.
David Duchovny
David Duchovny is best known as Fox Mulder
on the science fiction modern classic, The
X-Files.
However, Duchovny has been acting for decades,
early roles include playing the villains in
Don’t tell mom the Babysitter's Dead and
Beethoven, with a ponytail in the former to
really emphasize what an insufferable jerk
he was supposed to be.
During those unfortunate hair years, he appeared
on the Showtime series Red Shoe Diaries.
The series was soft core and considering Duchovny’s
later series, Californication, it definitely
should not surprise audiences to see him in
the series.
Simon Rex The name Simon Rex may only elicit
familiarity for those who watched a lot of
MTV in the 90s but his face should be more
familiar since he has appeared on Jack and
Jill, the short lived television series that
also starred Amanda Peet and Jamie Pressly,
as well as, television’s Felicity.
Rex has also appeared in a few of the Scary
Movies and a handful of other films.
The man gets a lot of work and some of that
work included a few adult movies, mostly solo
scenes with titles like Young, Hard, and Solo.
Rex went under the name of Sebastian for the
videos but has never claimed the videos were
not him nor has the existence of the adult
films caused any difficulty for him finding
work as he is also a model, rapper, and record
producer when he is not acting.
Not bad for an MTV VJ.
Jackie Chan
Jackie Chan is a household name thanks to
his acrobatic fighting skills and surprising
comedic chops.
Although he has been a working actor since
he was a child in the 1960s, he did not gain
international fame until the 1990s.
While a struggling actor Chan accepted a role
in an Adult film called All in the Family
where he took part in a single sex scene.
The film was not exactly a highlight of his
career but he has stated that he had to do
what he needed to pay his bills so it was
not a big deal.
With a prolific mainstream acting career,
it is just a minor role that was lost in the
shuffle and probably best stays lost.
Sylvester Stallone
Sylvester Stallone was definitely not an overnight
sensation, and surely part of his inspiration
for his film Rocky was his own underdog experience.
Before becoming a multi-hyphenate, Stallone
struggled not just to earn decent acting roles,
but anything that would give him money to
put a roof over his head.
It was after he found himself homeless and
sleeping in New York’s Port Authority bus
terminal that he ventured toward adult films.
The Party at Kitty and Stud’s was a softcore
film that paid Stallone $200 for his two days
of work.
Six years later after the massive success
of Rocky, the adult film was rereleased and
renamed The Italian Stallion.
Stallone, like a few others on our list, does
not regret doing the film as it was his only
way to earn rent money.
Adam West
For some, Adam West is Batman.
The 1960s campy Batman series featured a well-adjusted
Bruce Wayne compared to the more recent Dark
Knight interpretations.
In the 1980s, West decided to take a detour
mid-career and star in a few Showtime After
dark soft core films and The Happy Hooker
Goes to Hollywood.
The films are tame but the idea that non-threatening
and comforting Adam West decided to take a
few much more adult roles feels like a POW
and BOOM straight to the gut for audiences.
Matt Leblanc
For ten seasons, Matt Leblanc entered a majority
of living rooms in America every Thursday
night playing Joey Tribbiani of NBC’s Friends.
Before he was earning a cool million per episode,
he was a struggling actor appearing in a memorable
Heinz Ketchup commercial and Kelly Bundy’s
boyfriend on the popular sitcom Married with
Children and even went on to star in two failed
Married with Children Spin-offs.
Leblanc had a busy career before Friends,
but he managed to fit in some soft core porn
into his repertoire with Showtime’s Red
Shoe Diaries.
He had a small role in two episodes.
Just like David Duchovny and a few familiar
character actors, The Red Shoe Diaries was
a common stop on the road to fame.
Sibel Kikellie
German actress Sibel Kekilli has received
critical acclaim and awards for her performance
in the 2004 film Head-On.
She is most recognizable to American audiences
as Shae on HBO's Game of Thrones.
While Game of Thrones is known to be salacious,
it was her earlier work that raised a few
eyebrows.
Between 2001 and 2002, she appeared in thirteen
Adult films under the name, Dilara.
It was a career move she did not plan on sharing
and when she accepted an acting award for
work in Head-On, she tearfully explained that
she did not appreciate the press bringing
up her past and that it was a smear campaign
against her but she managed to move on just
fine.
Helen Mirren
Helen Mirren is such a polished and highly
accomplished actress, one may find it impossible
to imagine her in an adult film.
Even though she was appointed a Dame in 2003
and began her acting career at the Royal Shakespeare
Company, she was also in the erotic drama
Caligula in 1979.
The film sounds like a mainstream film as
it is a historical drama about the rise and
fall of a Roman Emperor but that Caligula
was a naughty ruler.
Legitimate and well-known actors Malcolm McDowell
and Peter O’ Toole also appeared in the
film, so she was not alone in venturing toward
explicit territory.
Caligula was produced by Penthouse founder
Bob Guccione and featured many “Penthouse
Pets”.
The pornographic film did not tarnish Mirren’s
reputation or acting career and she has continued
being one classy dame.
Traci Lords In the last two decades, Traci
Lords has carved herself out an impressive
acting career with her 90s film credits like
Crybaby and Blade to her television credits
in Melrose Place and Gilmore Girls.
Long before her expansive mainstream work,
she was a hard core porn actress.
In fact, older audiences may know her name
for the controversy that came with her porn
credits stemming from the fact that she was
under age when she starred in 75 films.
The Film Company, as well as Penthouse for
which she stripped while under age, claimed
that Lords gave them a fake ID and Birth Certificate,
which was true.
Obviously all of her films were ordered to
be removed from adult shops and video rental
stores.
Lords has worked steadily and unscathed by
her adult work and even poked fun of it by
appearing as a porn star in Kevin Smith’s
2008 comedy, Zack and Miri Make a Porno.
What do you think of our list?
Did we forget any actors who dipped into the
adult film pond?
Let us know in the comments.
Don’t forget to subscribe to the Screen
Rant channel to see more videos like this
one